voilà reste là ça ne mange pas de pain
tu as raison non je crois on le met là
on le met là haut mais là avec toute
façon il est pas ouvert non non non non
c'est à la fois une fois mais où c'est
dans les yeux
dans l'état sauvage avec mike horn
michaël youn a vomi pour quelle raison
parce qu'il a déposé un poulet parce
qu'il a mangé un insecte ou parce qu'il
a vu mike horn nu je les ai vus en plus
avaient attribué par ce qu'il a mangé un
un senior données médias mais champagne
mais vous excusez moi vous allez petit
c'est nul c'est pourquoi et ben non du
tout c'est le c'était pas un poulet
c'était un pentagone semblent mais
c'était la mort c'était dur qu'avec
l'alliance
oui mais c'est tellement jouissif ah
ouais tu es le ferait on doit à home et
d'ailleurs je vais le refaire
non c'est vrai tu as fait leur faire on
est resté très proche avec mike et je
vais le refaire mais peut-être sans
caméra comme ça pour le quai vrai avoue
très bien ouais bah tu peux pas mener
d'autres personnes matthieu delormeau
alors envahi l'est où monsieur au mieux
tomber la crevasse pâture avec moi voilà
pour mon ami je bois pas je dors peu oui
mais faut quand même savoir marcher bien
l'admettre
[Applaudissements]
avec quel chanteur français michaël youn
at il enregistré la chanson mauvaise foi
nocturne pascal ribot florent pagny
francky vincent passé alors mauvaise foi
nocturne s'est bien entendu francky
vincent ont fait exprès là tu fais
expérience je fais pas exprès mais j'ai
pas de mémoire des sens lassé du match
en mémoire des sens est atteinte à la
mémoire des sons et qu'elles sont une
question on regarde raconte pourquoi
toute cette série
moi en tout cas
quels éléments qui a trois ans vas-y
dégâts challenge où selon elles sont
désormais bien sûr noir de toi mais
repérer
[Musique]
j'avais 13 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord mais cette fois la parodie est
meilleur que l'original genou alors j'ai
tellement bien henri ii était bonne fm
c'est toujours plus surenchère des biens
n'avait pas d'ennemis non parce qu'elle
était très bonne aussi la légion et la
nuit sur le rapport aux normes et diam's
et vitaa c'était très bien mais là ça
fait du bien beau mais froid nocturne ne
faut pas dire qu'une parodie est mieux
que l'original saisirait pas de parodies
sur l'original donc mains mes bras mais
on connaît cela on ne l'ait arrêté de
vous prendre la tête pour na cboe
s'était pas perdue covage de petits
suisses
tu connais mon jour
moi si je te dis non non mais c'est
c'est chacun le sait bien sûr vas-y
comme le tien
je sais qu'hier et marianne jean becker
[Applaudissements]
dates en amérique latine
a jijel j'arrive excusez moi je débute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien de rien j'ai bossé tous les mois
commence comme l'étude
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les tournois si tu veux tu le mets
là et tu appuies aimé l'histoire madame
à des nantais partir le portugais
derrière dix ans
[Applaudissements]